Leon Constantine and France you you're
in both my classes anybody else in both
in both my classes
he for four of you the last three or
four sessions look like they're
paralleling you know enjoy the moment
while it lasts because you know the risk
free rate in the equity risk premium and
the beta discussion for the most part of
the same and everything so today we will
kind of diverge so easy days of
listening to the same thing twice are
done sir just just let you know
statement
okay
okay welcome back from your long weekend
I hope you had a time to pick a company
analyze it I hope you enjoyed yourself
and did that as well just a reminder
your first quiz is a week and a half
from today it's two weeks from Monday so
a week and a half from today on March
3rd I know again for those of you in
both my Corporate Finance in my
evaluation class you'll have backto back
quizzes so you know it is what it is so
yeah um it'll cover everything we do
through next Wednesday obviously so
it'll be primarily discount rates and
cash flows I'll tell you when in the
slides we'll stop until that's what
we're covered but everything you need
for the quiz is already up online the
review session pass quizzes and my
advice is if you want to prepare for the
quiz do more problems the more you get
your hands dirty working through
problems not just check the problem the
solution working through proms the
better off you're going to be so today's
class we're going to do a shift away
from discount we're going to talk about
cost of debt and cost of capital we're
going to complete that discussion but
then we're going to start on what I
think is the most critical part of
valuation assessing cash flows okay so
I'm going to start with a few questions
we will arrive you know we will talk
about more today but I want to get at
least set the
table remind me again when your
valuation is due
the last day of class you know what day
what day is that May 5th right and you
have to put a buy or a sell
recommendation as of that day right I
will give you some leeway and let you
use a Friday price from you know May 2nd
or something so you're comparing the
price from May
2nd to a valuation that technically
should be of May 2nd but I'll cut you
again some slack it might be from April
30th or April 15th but you want to get
your values close to price because
you're Deion has to be in real
time now if you think about the inputs
that go to valuation some of those
inputs get updated every second of every
day like what what are some of the
inputs in your valuation which will be
every day every minute of every day the
t-bond rate you mean the equity risk
premium I'll have a May 1st Equity risk
premum if you feel the urge to update it
hopefully it won't be that different
from April April 1st your market price
will get updated every moment of every
day but a big chunk of your information
comes from from financial statements
right and they don't get updated every
moment of every day or even every day or
even every week or even every month in
the US they get updated once every three
months and not even at the end of the
month it'll often be six weeks after the
month ends in a long and Tor torturous
way I'm setting up the first question do
you want the most updated information
you can get for things like T Bond rates
and market price will be today's data
but for things like accounting you are
stuck with whatever your most recent
financials look like so let's say you're
valuing a company today not even May 5th
you're valuing it
today other what what's the company of
value on the Swiss shoe company right
what do you what's your last annual
report look like which which your that
what
year but where what yours annual report
you have access to so when you go on the
website you have the 2024 numbers on
already updated or not because December
was the ending right no no that's not
the way it works right you can't say
because of your end is December the
annual report now is going to be the
2024 because it takes time for the
annual reports to come out I wouldn't be
surprised if you went to the website and
you check for the last annual report the
most recent annual report is the 2023
annual report okay for the moment at
least it will change as you go through
mine is last March and then I detect you
okay so we'll talk about that so your
annual report is so already you can see
the problem right the last annual report
is of might be of 2023 it might be March
of 2024 it might be June of 2024 Apple
has this very strange fiscal year end in
September of each year and you doing
evaluation in March or February or
April so but you can say that's my last
annual report I can I will stick with
that so that's the first choice the
second is Gabriel mentioned that he had
the last quarters numbers right can I
just multiply that by four
it's more updated right but what's the
problem multiplying last quarters
numbers by
four you take a retail firm and you take
the most recent quarter God only knows
what you get right there
seasonality so that's off the table so
you have the last annual report last
quarter multiplied by four that's not
going to work what can I add the last
four quarters
together fact what is that called when
we add the last four quarters together
it's called trailing 12 months last 12
months and in fact it's often LTM TTM
you will see this often in financials
last four
quarters or you can take if you have
numbers through September of 2024 let's
say the first nine months you can take
those and maybe fill in the last
quarters because there already analyst
estimates for what the 2024 numbers the
last quarter will look like and create
your own version of
2021 let's rule out what you should not
use the last quar multip M by four you
should not use because of seasonality
what about the last annual report even
if it's a 2023 report
Julie what kinds of companies would you
be able to get away with using the 2023
report companies were not much as say
you take Coca-Cola 2023 2024 you can be
2021 I could probably get away with it a
ramco what's different about 2024 oil
price might have changed if your company
is a mature company you can get away
using old financials and not pay a price
for it but you take Nvidia you take the
2023 report and you compared to the last
four quarters it's like I mean you're
looking at a very different
company my rule is never use the last
annual report go with trailing 12mon
data and in fact staying on the trailing
12- Monon data we talk about you know
when you say trailing 12 month dat it
sounds like a lot of work right because
what's your mind thinking about four
quarters of data I've got to get four
quartly
reports but you actually don't have to
if you have 110k the case of you have a
March 23rd 2020 and
110q I'm going to show you how with 110k
and 110 Q you can create a trailing 12
months it's not rocket sense you can add
basically you can net out the numbers
and come up with the trailing 12 month
numbers so the key point is get as
updated as you can on the information
some will get updated every minute of
every day some will get updated every
quarter and some might you might be
stuck with the annual report data I'll
tell you in the US while I use trailing
12mth data for most accounting numbers
there are things like stock options
outstanding that will show up only in
the annual
report nothing I can do about it I'm
going to take that as most updated
number and work with it the second
question this is more of a generic
question once we get earnings for a
company we need to subtract out what
it's reinvesting and one big measure for
reinvesting is what a company is putting
into Capital
expenditures I'll give you the
definition of capital expenditures that
my accounting professor gave me and then
I'm going to list out some items and you
tell me whether you would think of them
as capital expenditures or not I was
told that if you have an expend
expenditure where you have benefits over
many years it's a capital expenditure
right keep that definition your mind
because I'm going to read off a list of
items and I want you to use that
definition not what you see in an
accounting statement or financial
statement to tell whether it's capex
it's expense that creates benefits over
many years building a manufacturing
plant unless you have a really short
life cycle product right if your product
just last one year you might actually
argue that but in most cases plant you
going what about R&D
expenses super care PEX right what
company in its right mind does R&D
expecting to get a benefit this year if
you're lucky maybe two years maybe 5
years if you're a technology firm and if
you're a pharmaceu itical firm you might
have to wait 8 10 15 years Nova nois is
living off R&D it did in 2013 and
14 or maybe even earlier for OIC and
wovi what about advertising by a
consumer product
company there are two reasons companies
advertise right one is to get you to buy
products today that's an operating
expense but if you watch the Super Bowl
ads they were not about getting you to
buy stuff today they were about building
brand name and you know so if you saw an
ad for on it's really about not getting
you to go buy on it make you aware of
this company the brand name and if that
is your biggest asset let's face it for
a company like Coca-Cola and on and Nike
your biggest asset may be your brand
name the money you spend building that
brand name is really capital
expenditure by now you see the pattern
here right much of what we think of as
capex in a financial statement is
oldtime manufacturing capex so when you
go to the statement of cash flows for
your company look under capex you're not
getting R&D you're not getting
recruiting and training expenses for a
consulting firm which is basically their
biggest asset is building up human
capital you're getting old-fashioned
land building equipment
machinery which effectively also means
that when you're valuing a technology
company in fact most companies you can't
trust the
capex you have to come up with the with
a measure of capex that's far broader
than the accounting capex because you
got to C if you don't do that everything
is going to get misstated
question yeah that's part of it too
right so any money you so think long
that's basically go back to the core
definition and say an accountants are
not consistent with their own core
definitions right so that's what we're
doing is we're holding them accountable
saying if that's your definition of
capex I'm going I mean if you're looking
at a company like Uber or
Airbnb what's the biggest capex you
think at those
companies software is part of it Cal
customer acquisition costs right how do
they get them by giving you freebies to
try the
platform that will show up as a cost but
to them this is how you build up your
business is having more users more
writers more subscribers so already you
can see that the companies of today the
capex you see on the statement of cash
flows doesn't capture what they're
actually putting in for future growth so
we're going to come back and address all
of those issues so let me or one final
question I want to kind of draw a
distinction between two different tax
rates we're going to go back and forth
in this class the first is called an
effective tax
rate what what's an effective tax rate
think of it is you take total taxes paid
by a company and divide by total taxable
income you have an effective tax rate so
you pay 200 million in taxes on a
billion dollars in income 200 divide by
a billion is 20% that's your effective
tax rate the marginal tax rate so the
effective tax rate you will find in the
financial statements and even if you
don't find it go to the income statement
take taxes paid divide by taxable income
you got the effective tax rate the
marginal tax rate is the tax rate you
pay on the next dollar of income or the
last dollar of income you won't find it
in company financials this you find in
the tax code let's see how familiar you
are with the Us corporate tax code
what's a federal corporate tax rate in
the US right
now 21 right what was it in 2017 before
the
tax it was 35% so 35% to 21% and here's
the weird thing
us tax laws because of the way you got
to get through the Senate and you have
to get passed through with a filibuster
you got to reconcile because of that tax
codes come with finite lives so the 2017
tax code is expected to completely go
away at the end of 2025 it falls fact
it's there's a cliff you'll approach and
if you don't fix it it reverts back it's
a weirdest stuff you've ever seen you
know who does this but this is the way
it
works so it could very well be 35% so
who won the election this year might
have a big effect on evaluation because
you know to the extent that you know the
tax code gets extended when you value
companies today you might use a 21%
starting point but if it had been a
different outcome and you said that tax
code is not going to get renewed you
would have to actually adjust your
marginal tax rate going forward because
you expect it to be you know so this
year actually the question is will the
marginal tax rate get lower rather than
higher because there is stock at least
of the reconciliation this year lowering
the corporate tax rate from 21% to a
lower number for at least a subset of
companies Callum question about all the
capex and taxes because part of the
problem like I I agree with you that
like there are things that are
investments in your company but some of
them are cash tax deductible some of
them are right so when we're looking at
like getting our free tax FL we count
expense like advertising I think you're
raising a very interesting question the
tax law is the tax law you're not going
to change it know it's got nothing to do
with good sense bad sense it's what's
tax deductible there's no reason why we
can't treat customer acquisition cost is
capex and not a bring it's easy to
capture the tax benefit from it right so
I will actually have my cake needed to I
will move the items into capex if I feel
they're being mistreated but I'll still
compute the tax is based on the existing
tax code that's where that way I don't
leave any of the tax benefits behind
separate exactly and it's actually very
easy to do I'll give you a shortcut to
do it because you have a good point
which is we're moving it all these items
from operating to Capital expenses but
the tax law still allows me to subtract
R&D as an operating expense I'm going to
take it I'm not going to go to the IRS
and say look can I spread it out over 5
years it doesn't make sense for me to do
it so I think you're absolutely right we
have to know tie up some loose Sense on
taxes so effective tax rates marinal tax
rates right which one do you think is
going to be higher for most
companies the marginal and why well I
want to start digging on this because
this is going to tell you what to do
Jacob why tax would have any like tax
savings from last year losses or
something one is carry forward so that's
one thing and the other is you have very
clever tax lawyers you might be able to
defer taxes it might also be with us
company we have foreign income after
2017 and this is more puts us more in
line with the rest of the world if you
have income in a country with a 15%
corporate tax rate you pay the 15%
corporate tax rate and you're done
there's no extra tax due that didn't
used to be the case before 2017 already
you can see a possibility of of
effective tax Apple's effective tax rate
is
12% some of it is no no losses carried
forward they haven't lost money in
Forever is tax tax defer a lot of it is
income in locations where they have a
much lower corporate tax rate okay
that's not going to go away you know as
so one of the things we're going to talk
about is what do you do when the
effective tax rate is less than the
marginal tax rate valuation do you leave
it at that lower number do you move it
towards the marginal tax rate and I'm
laying the foundations for answering
that question and you're going to see
the answers are going to be different
for different companies for Apple we
might leave it at 15% below the 21
% because if they continue to be a
global company getting 50% of the
revenues outside it's never going to
catch up but if it's deferred
taxes we have a problem right because
eventually those tax are going to come
to you there I'm going to be more likely
to move from 15 to 21% so let those two
things kind of move around and think
about the difference because you're
going to see it play out in valuation in
different ways when we do cost to debt
as opposed to cash flows but those are
last year the average effective tax rate
for US companies was
18% you know the average effective tax
rate in
2016 before the tax code was it was
19.2% you say but the marginal tax rate
went from 35 to
21% you know we talk a lot about the
marginal tax rate but companies when you
have marginal tax rate of 35% were
playing all kinds of the games so the
actual net loss in tax revenue from
going from 35 to 21% was minuscule if
you look at the total corporate taxes
paid in 2018 as opposed to 2016 right so
the effective tax rate captures all of
those actions that companies take to
keep their tax rates low the marginal
tax rate whatever in the call
incidentally for the US the federal
corporate tax rate is
21% the reason I emphasize that is if
you step if you as a company you have
revenues in California in addition to
the federal corporate tax rate you have
to pay state taxes and if you're in New
York City local taxes so by the time you
add all of that up the marginal tax rate
in the US is closer to 25% which happens
to be roughly where the marginal tax
rate is for much of the rest of the
world so the 2017 tax code actually
brought the tax marginal tax in the US
closer to where it is in Europe for most
of Europe I think Germany's at 29 no
Ireland is at 12 so those are the limits
in Europe but much of Europe is around
25% but it's going to come into play as
we talk about cost of debt and why
companies borrow money and what the
benefits of thatt are
right so let me turn the lights on for
whatever reason people
let me go back to where I left you
on where we left off in the
packet so back in the valuation packet
for those of you tracking which packet
so that was the start of the class let's
go back to where we were we were talking
about building up to a cost of equity
and we had the first two ingredients
nailed down right at least partially
Jessica remind me again if I asked you
what a risk-free
is how would you answer the
question before you do that ask me in
what currency right you are quick to
jump to US dollars right so first thing
with risk free rates is don't start the
conversation until you have currency in
Elda right it's in US Dollars I'm going
to use a treasury rate shortterm or long
term not in valuation right because
everything is longterm you're looking at
cash flow so you going to go to the
long-term treasury rate and you done
other currencies it's a little bit of a
mess because you might have no default
free entity but the risk-free rate is
always currency driven it's got nothing
to do with where your company's
Incorporated it's nothing to do with
your frame of reference or what what
currency the company borrows at you make
a choice Jacob help me on the equity
risk premium to come up with the equity
risk premium for a
company start with the equity risk
premium in the country but first what
country whatever country so before I do
that what's the first thing thing I have
to ask where do you do business right so
don't jump to the country because then
you're going to give it the equity risk
the country in which it's Incorporated
but as we said you can be an Indian
company with 90% of your revenues in the
US so with the equity risk you start
with where the business operates and if
you want to use revenues that's fine you
want to use production for natural
resource company you might do that and
you then you build up to a weighted
average of the equity risk free risk
free rate Equity risk free what's the
last ingredient to get to my costomer
Equity I need a beta okay let's talk
about betas because there's an immense
amount of noise around betas especially
after you've taken a finance class
because in a finance class what are you
taught betas come from regressions
you're under regression of returns in
the stock against returns in the market
index the slope of the line is the beta
and statistically you can see the
rationale beta measures risk related to
the market and beta captures therefore
that correlation or co-variance with the
market it's a terrible way to think
about betas in my view first because it
makes it a statistical number right when
people ask where the bet is come from
they come from a
regression and if you remember your
statistics when you run a regression you
get a slope If This Were A statistics
class you're trying to put in standard
errors right below the slope how
uncertain you about the slope a practice
we very conveniently forget after that
statis just like in the equity risk
premium the promet regression bait is at
threefold first they're noisy you've
heard that before Equity risk premiums
you hear that now with betas they're
noisy because they come with a big
standard eror second they're backward
looking by definition because to get a
beta I've got to run a regression of not
the next five years of returns because I
don't have them but the last five years
of returns I did that for Disney
remember think of how much Disney has
changed over the last 5 years there was
no Disney streaming at the start and by
the end you got this big chunk of money
being spent on Disney streaming
companies change and the beta you use
will reflect the business or businesses
your company was in during the period of
the
regression and we're going to talk a
little bit about how debt plays out here
but debt can make your beta higher
because it increases Equity risk and do
companies debt policies change over time
absolutely they can go from no debt lots
of debt or lots of debt to no debt and
that can change your bait as
well so I'm I'm going to dig a grve for
regression betas and bury them the way
I'm going to do this is by taking you
through a series of beta
examples to explain why it's so
dangerous to trust a beta 95% of the
world if you ask them where the beta
comes from they go to Bloomberg they
print off a beta page if you're an
investment bank there's a beta for my
company I'm going to give you the
ammunition to take that beta page apart
so let me
start with a company that most of you
must might have heard about GoPro
remember GoPro in its Heyday what did it
do it provided cameras for oversharing
overactive people I think basically you
went on a 3our hike you put a GoPro on
your head you recorded the whole thing
you carried it live as if people cared
watching you for three hours and a hike
but it had its glorious moment right big
Growth Company so I know ran the
regression for I went to Bloomberg and
the nice thing about Bloomberg and I
gave you the instructions on how to do
this once you pick a company you type in
beta you get a page like
this there's a regression beta page for
Bloom and it looks great there is my
Beta
1.64 the adjusted beta you can ignore
it's just a raw beta push towards one
but basically this is a regression beta
you're tempted right I'm Val GoPro
there's the beta 1.60 1.40 before you
use that down I want to keep going down
see a standard of the
beta B tell me what the standard error
what what the standard error there for
the
beta
50 right my regression beta is 1.60 my
standard error is 0.50 I might as well
have told you absolutely nothing right
the true beta could be somewhere from 6
to
2.6 that's what I mean by noising nice
thing about Bloomberg bait is they give
you the bait and they give you the noise
term everybody ignores the noise
term maybe you need to draw attention to
say why you ask me to use the beta look
at the range around the beta now once in
a while though you might get a great
looking beta you should be even more
terrified or what you just found this is
a beta page I've saved for almost 25
years it's a beta page I printed off for
Nokia in 2000 this is amazing regression
R squ is close to 100% standard a is
close to zero every point is on the line
right If This Were A statistics class
I'd get a go
medal but I have a question why is my
Nokia beta looking so much better than
my GoPro beta is it because it's a more
mature
company no if I made it know I could
have taken Nokia and you know GoPro and
run run it similar I I'd have got a much
better looking regression with the
choice as well Danny what do you
think look at the index right you know
what blg does when you ask for a it's
very parochial you ask for the beta for
a German company to run it against the
Dax an Indian company against the sensex
a US company G the S&P
500 I asked for Nokia which is a Finnish
company and guess where Bloomberg is
going it's going to
Helsinki that's a that's a Helsinki I'll
be quite honest I had no idea what was
in the in the hex I thought it was a
witches Cur I ran this regression
and I took a deeper look and I wish I
had not in 2000 I think Nokia owned
Finland it was 80% of the index so what
is this a regression of Nokia against
Nokia and what do we finding an awful
lot of the time the two move together
congratulations if you'd find anything
else this would be a statistical
artifact you should publish in every
paper in the
world this is a useless regression in
here why why do we say we use betas it's
because the marginal investor is
Diversified right so I want to take a
look at who the marginal investor in
Nokia was in 2000 it was easy to find I
took the top 17 investors at the top of
the list was
bar and they held Nokia as part of their
Global Index Fund if you're barlay you
hold Nokia as part of a global Index
Fund you don't measure risk against the
hex in fact if you want to redo the
regression one of the nice things about
Bloomberg because you can change the
index what would you change Danny what
what did you do replace the hex
with or some Global Equity index and
there is one actually on Bloomberg
called the msci global it's the most
widely used Global index there's a
symbol for it I'll send you the symbol
you can take any beta page for noia or
for for on Bloomberg and replace the
local index with a global index when I
do that I get a more sensible beta page
but it comes with a consequence what
will the standard error look like it's
going to be much bigger you run a beta
regression right a big standard error is
a feature not a bug because most of the
risk in a company in a diversified
portfolio is going to be company
specific risk and that's all you get it
from the C question you so if you went
and put this against a more Global index
the stand error is say 50 like the other
example you're saying how like to me it
seems like there's not much validity
behind that B There is it basically I
told you I was going to dig a grave for
a single regression ba and bu because
these are what one pass in Time One
stock one index There Is No Escape
Hatcher there's no way to fix it I've
seen people sit in front of a Bloomberg
terminal play games with the page
thinking they can make this better and
your point is there's no endgame here
because if you do it right you're going
to get a big standard ear nothing you're
going to do that makes that go away is
helping me but there is a way out and we
talk about it's a statistical way out
and my my solution is to try to take
that statistical way out so for the
moment though I think you can see what
the problem is when you look at a single
regression
paina let's try a different company
remember
GameStop what a stock it was right
course as a as a business what did it do
I mean if you are of the right age and
you were remember you know you might all
be too young to do it but there was a
time when people used to go to malls if
you've never been in a mall it's this
big place lots of different stores
really nothing to do you had no money to
spend but you could just wander around
the mall all day long and that's what
teenagers would do until they G to the
came to the GameStop store and it'd be
very crowded because in the GameStop
store you could stop and play games on
the computer you didn't have any money
to buy a game but the reason they let
you play the game is the minute you got
to a threshold you came back to the
store and bought the game you
wanted so it's a mall store business
brick and mor retail whose time is come
and
gone and so coming into 2020
2021 the perspective was hey this is
this isn't we're looking at the end game
here and there were a lot of people who
decide to sell short on gamestock we
talked about you know this at the start
of the class about how Revenge can
sometimes drive it and of course it then
became the target of all these the this
group on Reddit called Wall Street bets
that decide to take GameStop and you can
see that spike in the prices so if you
looked at the price vola this is a stock
that went from $20 to 400 back to 20 is
that a risky stock you think don't think
too long clearly goes from 20 to 400
back to 20 you are incredibly terrified
so I want to run a regression B to see
how terrified I should be you know what
I get got as my regression but it's
tough to read there I got a negative
beta for the stock
so first I want you to ask a question
how can an incredibly volatile stock
have a negative
beta what what beta measures is not just
volatility but how that volatility is
correlated with the market right so if
you have something that's volatile for a
reason that have nothing to do with the
market it'll actually have a low baa
biotech companies have low betas even
though they're risky companies because
much of the risk is company specific the
fact that your drug didn't pass the the
third phase of a FD is has nothing to do
with the
market most of the risk year in fact all
of the risk year is so company specific
that when you run the regression the
regression what's happening in the stock
has nothing to do with the market in
fact it's a little inversely related
Market because strange people buying and
selling the stock for strange
reasons but here's my question if your
valueing GameStop at this time do you
really want to put a negative beta into
your because what will a negative beta
lead you to end up with a cost of equity
that's actually lower than your risk
free rate you'd be insane to do that
right again a regression beta that's
completely leading you off the
tracks and finally there is this
phenomenon of gaming that happens once
you decide regression ba is the way to
go at the start of the class we talked
about bias that often you come into a
valuation either wanting a high number
or a low
number let's say you are valuing in this
case Bombardier Bombardier is a Canadian
Aerospace company makes these smaller
commercial
aircraft and you want to get a beta from
Bombardier bombarda is traded on the
Toronto Stock
Exchange and it's traded as an ADR in
the US so what you have in this page is
the regression the beta that I got by
regressing the bardier ad against the
S&P
500 or Bombardier the local listing
against the Toronto
exchange I get two different betas in
fact the betas are 1.70 and 1.21 so
let's say your bias was that you wanted
to find Bombardier cheap you want to get
a high value for Bombardier you sit in
front of a Bloomberg you try these two
be honest with me which one are you
going to show me as the beta for the
company given that you have a bias
the low one because it'll give you a
lower cost of equity and you claim
you'll claim this this is the beta page
for the fact that you tried 15 other
Pages before you got to this one is
completely missed what I'm trying to say
the next time a banker holds up a beta
page for a
company before he goes on say how many
beta pages did you try till you got this
one because think of the number of
things you can change in this page you
can change the starting point and the
ending point you can change from daily
to weekly to monthly you can change the
index you're going to be able to move
the beta all over the place which by
itself is not the issue but it means
that whatever bias you have you'll end
up finding a beta that reflects that
bias so we've got the whole deep enough
let's bu regression bet is they're
noisy you should get even more terrified
when they're not because the index is
probably misspecified
in periods of volatility the volatility
is nothing to do with the market
Merc when it was targeted in the voox
lawsuits ended up the beta close to zero
because every month the one thing that
drove the stock price was did you lose
that lawsuit or win on it and finally
this gaming phenomenon where if you give
yourself enough time and you can change
the parameters you can get pretty much
any beta you want for the
company so with that lead in I'm going
to take a step back when you talk about
betas you are in a sense buying into the
capital asset price model and when you
buy the capital asset pricing model
you're bringing 65 years maybe 70 years
of portfolio Theory as baggage with
you and there are people out there who
don't like any of this stuff some some
high-profile Warren Buffett has been
famously quoted as saying you know
Charlie Monga too no bet is you know
it's it's a it's it's a terrible way of
measuring risk bait is are bad I accept
that bait is are noisy they flawed but
what I don't accept is what people do as
a consequence they say I don't like
betas therefore I'm not going to do
intrinsic
valuation so I'm going to give you if
you don't like betas or you run into
people who don't like betas a way out of
this box because betas to me are just a
means to an end they measure of relative
risk and if you tell me you don't like
Bas I'm going to ask you why so I want
somebody to play the game you know there
might be somebody here who doesn't like
BS you might have worked with people so
if somebody doesn't like Bas I'd like
you to volunteer yourself because I'll
lead you to the process of what your
alternative should be for Bas cuz you
probably were skeptical when you heard
about vas in your class Diversified
investor we run a regression and I'm
building a whole thing so anybody want
to be the candidate for not liking
Bas
no go ahead diction so what what is it
about Bas you don't like
like you said I I don't believe that I
can use it in in Valu but but I'm trying
to dig why can't you use it right so
I'll give I'll give you a starting point
there are two big assumptions we make
with betas one is the notion that the
modu investors is Diversified right
that's an assumption the second is that
stock prices allow me to capture that
okay so which part of those those are
the two big ones so which part makes you
more concerned the fact that the module
investor Diversified or that I'm using
stock prices okay so and the reason
being we're doing intrinsic valuation we
said markets make mistakes why would I
use a market price based measure of risk
if I'm doing intrinsic valuation this
would be what you run into over and over
again if you go to Omaha Nebraska and
you talk to Value investors they so
that's crazy using betas that comes from
prices we intrinsic value people okay
let me take that to the next step I
agree with you it's a market price and
you don't like markets so you got to
give something else right if you're in
the intrinsic value space rather than
looking at volatility in prices what
might you look at you know what's a much
more intrinsic
number maybe earnings right the one
catches you don't get earnings every day
so you have to use quar I could compute
a standard deviation your company's
earnings just like I do stock price
let's say I come up with
36% I can't use the 36% because I have
no idea whether it's high or low so I
want to standardize it what's the most
logical way to standardize it compute
this for every company in the market
let's say it's 24% on average if I
divide the 36 by the 24 I come up with a
number that looks very much like a beta
right 1.50 and now I'm playing your game
you want earnings volatility I'm going
to give you earnings
volatility you might say look I don't
think it's earnings it's debt that I'm
worried about when I think about
risk that companies might get into
trouble so I can compute debt ratios
again my objective is to take what
whatever you tell me you think about as
risk and convert it into a number that
looks like a beta so prices are what bug
you the Assumption we're using prices I
can fix
it but there are people who say it's a
marginal investor assumption that bugs
me I'm in a market where investors are
not Diversified why are you assuming the
marginal investors divers if that is
your reason for not liking baas I'm
going to take a different
path I can then what are the reasons we
use beta is we look at the portion of
the variance that you cannot diversify
away that's what beta is you've just
told me that you think investors are not
Diversified so you're basically arguing
that you should be looking at the total
standard deviation something we don't do
because we assume Diversified investors
but that's a number that I can pull from
the
market let's say it's
50% again I'm going to look at that
average across all stocks let's say 30%
50 divid by 30 gives me a relative
standard deviation of 1. 67 it comes
with none of the B baggage of
Diversified investor to me beta is not
the place where I want to fight your you
know this is not the hill I want to die
on if you don't like betas I'm going to
come up with a different measure of
relative risk that captures what you
think about risk I'm going to put it
where I put in the beta so in the case
of um standard deviation and earnings
I'm going to put in that 1.5 that I got
from and and move
on because ultimately all I need is a
measure of relative
risk so if you don't like portfolio
Theory fine throw it all out right but
don't tell me you don't adjust for risk
because that I don't get give me your
proxy for risk what you think of as risk
and I'll convert to something that looks
like a
beta so if you don't like the
Diversified investors you can use
relative standard
deviation know so if you're valuing a
private company might say owners are not
Diversified you're basically using a Rel
standard deviation I call it a total
beta and I'll take you through the
process you can use proxy models where
essentially you say look I'm not going
to even Tred to measure risk with a beta
but small companies are are risky big
companies are safe technology companies
are risky as you make these
choices remember this is a flawed
measure of risk as well you're replacing
one flawed measure of risk with a
different one and you'd ask yourself am
I going to be less exposed to Mistakes
by doing this than by using the
traditional beta there's a reason I
stick with the beta I mean I I'm
comfortable with it I know it's all of
its flaws it's like being married for
how many years have I been
married long time 30 my 38th anniversary
is coming hey by this time we know each
other right so in a sense bet is like
you know spouse you've been with for 38
years you know you you know you get up
in the morning you know all of its
problems and they the beta knows all of
your problems and you kind of move on so
I'm okay with replac not my spouse but
the beta with something you want to use
instead because ultimately my end game
is I want a hurdle rate I want a cost
the capital I'm going to get there by
hook or by crook right so you will run
into people who will make it make this
their big thing I don't like
pis concede that to them so I'm willing
to use something other than betas move
on cuz ultimately want to H me
other value investors don't value
companies and that sounds like a weird
thing to do how do value investors find
undervalued
stocks they screen they screen for low
PE so basically they're doing pricing
and this is my problem with value
investing is if you don't actually value
companies why is there a value in your
description
you're just low price screeners right
that's what you are and then you wonder
where's the payoff to Value investing so
when value investing doesn't work they
said this this shows that valuation
doesn't work you haven't valued a
company how do you know what works or
doesn't if you haven't tried in the
first
place last time I was in Omaha I didn't
go to the meeting I talked to 200
portfolio managers who are people who
come to Omaha every year for decades ask
some question how many people in this
room
have actually valued a company three
people out of 200 have actually valued a
company they were willing to talk about
good management you know would look at
all I said I I accept all of that stuff
but you're basically saying I'll buy a
stock with a low p ratio and good
management that's a screening device
it's not valuation it's not
complete because you're not willing and
and so you're using this as an excuse
for not having to Value companies and
one more thing there are a lot of people
who will take the cap risk fre rate plus
beta times risk premium and then they
was really these are called what are
called buildup approaches to a cost of
equity I call it makeup approaches
because basically when you get a number
that's too low what do you do you start
adding numbers small cap premium 4%
still not high enough or let's add an
liquidity premium another 3% still not
high enough a private company premium
another 9% still not and then you get
really desperate a company specific risk
premum which you completely make up and
add on you've really lost control this
process at which point my response is
why you even doing intrinsic valuation
if you're just going to make up a
discount rate you know in the first
place
yes small cap premiums though we we do
know that small cap compan do use
historically no wait wait what's that
history based on
1927 through 2024 I updated just last
week the small cap prum for the US was
3.03% smallest de
you know the standard ER in that number
is right it's about 1.67% so already
statistically pushing the margin but I'm
willing to con see that's close enough
there a small cap but if you take that
1927 through 2024 time period and you
break it up into 1927 through 1979 and
1980 through 2024 between 1927 and 1979
the small T premium is about
7% between since 1980 there's been no
small care premium when did was the
farmer frch study which is 1992 which
was 13 years still you were close enough
the the further away you get from
1979 the more tenuous this whole thing
becomes it's amazing how much stuff in
valuation we do with this lagging
history carrying us along so I actually
will will send you the small cap
spreadsheet that I created where I said
you give me a so basically you can pick
the starting point and the ending point
for your time period and as you move
1927 1930 1940 1950 you see the premium
shrinking and by the time you get to the
mid 70s and you start off every time
period since then the small cap premium
has been zero or negative and which
suggests that there's something
fundamentally that has shifted in
markets and I think here's what shifted
you know how difficult it was to get
information on a small cap company 60
years ago you I'm not saying you were
around 60 years ago do this but getting
the data there was an information
problem there's a liquidity problem
there was a trading problem there were
no ETFs that did just or index funds
that did small cap stocks today we have
Vanguard index funds that have centered
around small cap companies that get so I
think there's a reason the small cap
premium has disappeared so when people
keep using that premium and basing it on
historical data I think they're letting
the tail of the first half of the of the
Data Drive the entire process so that's
a capm plus there are accounting risk
measures yes
arees from being small yeah that's a
different question that's always been my
issue small cap is just a stand in for
something else right because there's
nothing inherently risky about being
small or large I can think of small
businesses that are incredibly safe and
large business are incredibly risky we
just allowed it to be a proxy something
standing in if you don't like price
based measures then you got to go with
accounting numbers and I'll be quite
honest I'll take market prices over
accounting numbers but that's just me
right you can look at earnings you can
look at balance sheet ratios you can do
the ultimate Z score if you want and but
it's more useful in fixed income than in
equity as a measure of risk but
something like that you can use even
qualitative risk models where you
basically assign companies to five
buckets the know value line used to be a
big investment you know investment
newsletter for a long time they used to
classify companies into risk into five
groups one 2 3 4 5 I'm okay with that as
well I'll just give different costs of
equity for each group I amet as I said
completely flexible on how I adjust for
risk if you tell me what bothers you
about the way you're measuring
risk one final point about bait is
before we leave before we establish a
different way of thinking about Bas now
as I said most people ask them where the
betas come from they say they come from
regressions you dig a Little Deeper they
actually they they come from a service
they come from Bloomberg they come from
B You Dig a Little Deeper they say it
comes from a regression but I want to
dig even deeper ultimately betas don't
come from regressions they don't come
from Services they come from choices you
make as a company let's go through the
three choices and there only three that
determine whether you have a high beta
an average beta or low beta tell me what
you do as a
company if the product or service you
provide is discretionary the more
discretionary it is to your customers
the higher your B dat will be as a
company Jacob what do I mean by
discretionary what what am I talking
about discretionary in the sense of I
can delay buying it I can defer buying
it if that's the kind of product or
service you provide you have a higher
beta because in Good Times you will do
well in bad times people will defer it
so the retail
business luxury retail is going to have
a much higher bet than department stores
department stores will have a higher bet
than discount retail and discount retail
will have a higher beta than grocery
retail because you can
live without your Gucci but you can't
live without food but even within
grocery retail you'd expect Whole Foods
to have a higher beta than Kroger I went
to both stores yesterday the eggplant
was three times as expensive at Whole
Food but was
organic when you doing well you're
making a lot of money you go for the
organic eggplant you lose your job trust
me you'll be okay okay with the
inorganic stuff cuz you're going to die
anyway so you can see even within
businesses you can see variant sprouts
and Whole Foods will have higher betas
than Kroger's or the Walmart Target
grocery version where you go for the
lowest
prices now they mentioned the company
he's working on is on right Sports work
I've gone on their website I've never
hit the buy button I just go to look
because seems a little expensive to me
maybe because I'm old $150
$200 it's Cloud it's got big big heels
supposed to make my feet feel
better I would expect on to have a
higher bet than you know something that
I just put on my feet and the problem in
the re the Footwear business is that all
brand name companies are all pretty
highly priced it's not like you can get
you know cheap Footwear but basically Al
you're looking for how discretion the
product is the more discretionary the
higher the bet that's a first stop so
the company you picked and I'm assuming
you pick the company I want you to start
thinking about what they do and if it's
a b2c company it's easier than a B2B
company because b2c you can think about
the product would I be able to put delay
buying it or defer buying it and the
answer is yes I it second stop tell me
something about your cost structure why
does cost structure matter the greater
the proportion of your cost that are
fixed cost cost the higher your beta
will be as a company think of what when
you have a lot of fixed costs in Good
Times you make lots of money in bad
times you lose lots of
money in
2020 Marriott collapsed as a company why
because Co shut hotels down and its cost
structure remained with those huge fixed
cost you had to keep those hotels
cleaned up you couldn't just let you
know let everybody go because people
would move into the hotel rooms and
never move out but Airbnb reduced its
cost by 80% why because it's a platform
you send people home and you have less
costs I would expect Airbnb to have a
lower beta than marot it's got less
fixed cost so with your company I want
to start thinking about cost structure
what kind of cost and I'll give you
Clues you can look for in the financial
statements that will kind of tell you
whether your company's high or low
operating leverage and thirdly when you
borrow money you create a fixed cost you
did not have until you borrow the money
interest expenses in Good Times no
problem you pay the interest expenses in
bad times you're still forced to pay the
interest expenses which makes your
Equity income much more volatile that's
it those are the three things that drive
your beta what do you do product and
service how discretionary is it what
does your cost structure look like and
how much have you
borrowed now do you see why airlines are
insanely
structured what's a cost structure look
like for an airline
incredibly fixed right the aircraft the
fuel the the employees and if you have a
lot of fixed cost as a company what
should you do in terms of borrowing
money borrow as little as you can you
already have a lot of fixed cost what
strikes me and this is part of the
insanity of how slow companies are to
adjust to changes is Airlines to borrow
money on top of the fixed cost and then
they wonder why they keep going bankrupt
every five six
years right the reason they do it is
prior to 1977 when you had before you
had deregulation you could do Cost Plus
pricing so effectively control the
pricing so you could pass it through
that's no longer the
case so as you think about Bas I want
you to start thinking about your
business economics in your company
yeah borrow less right but then why
infrastru compan have why so
traditionally infrastructure companies
have borrowed money to build
infrastructure why did AT&T why was AT&T
able to borrow money when it was Marbel
in the early part why were they able to
borrow money and get away with it what
were they building
into a monopoly that was a trade-off
legislation was actually passed
protecting AT&T from competition why cuz
without that being passed there's no way
you spending billions of dollars on
infrastructure and not control the
pricing and there in lies the so why
isn't more infrastructure being built in
India I you know a student of this class
became the head of Morgan Stanley
infrastructure and he quit after four
years and here's the problem he said
we're spending a lot of money the
government tells us we will have this
nice secure Market but they keep
changing their
mind and if they keep changing the mind
we're not spending billions up front
it's a challenge with infrastructure
with privately funded infrastructure is
without giving pricing power then you're
really are you know it's really
difficult to figure out the economics of
how you make this work you have like a
long contract the Govern then might help
you but you know but it's not just a
contract the pricing has to be set as
well so if the government says we will
pay you a price that'll be renegotiated
5 years from now having a 50-year
contract doesn't quite help you right so
it does mean that without that pricing
power it becomes much more difficult to
carry that fixed cost
so here's my way around regression betas
I don't like them I haven't used them in
40 years in valuing a company but I need
to come up with something to replace
them here's what I'm going to do I'm
going to start with the bait of the
business or businesses you're in sounds
difficult but it's actually you tell me
the three or four or five businesses
you're in I can actually tell you
roughly speaking what the bait of being
in those
businesses in fact if I have the
information I might even be able to
correct that b for the fact that you
have higher fixed cost or lower fixed
cost if you're if I gave you the betas
for hotel companies and you're looking
at Airbnb you might want to use a lower
beta so the Second Step I'm going to see
if I have to adjust for operating
leverage and I'll talk about the
informational problem you going to run
into and the third step I'm going to
bring in the debt you have as a company
because that too can affect your beta so
let's start with the first
step when you want to estimate the beta
for a company you first have to figure
out the business the company is in
and I want you to be careful about
defining business because there are two
mistakes people make often they Define
business too specifically my company is
in the shrimp fishing business no no no
no your company is in the food
processing business because the minute
you start to Define it as very narrow
segments you're going to run into
trouble even thinking about the risk of
that business I'm going to find publicly
traded companies with business and I'm
going to clean up for it but when you do
you're going to get what's called a pure
P play beta beta for being in this
business and I'll talk about the
mechanics of doing this so if you're in
one business I'll give you that one Pure
Play bait if you're in three business
I'll take a weight to average so
essentially this key part in this
process is finding the business you're
in and finding the betas of other
companies in that
business so that'll give me a beta for
the business a steel company or in the
steel business I can give you the beta a
pure play beta for being in the steel
business but then comes the Stony issue
of within the steel steel business
aren't there some companies with higher
fixed cost and others with lower fixed
cost the answer is absolutely and I'd
love to be able to correct for it I know
mechanically how to do it but you know
what the biggest challenge in correcting
for operating
leverages take a look at your company's
income statement or financial statements
collectively and I challenge you to tell
me how much of the cost in this company
of fixed costs and you can make guesses
right you can say cost of good sold is
probably variable cost sgna is probably
fixed cost but you have no wayno the
biggest challenge in correcting for
financial for operating Leverage is
getting information on fixed costs and
variable cost at individual
companies if I can do that I can clean
up for the beta so I don't have to
assign every Steel company the steel
company steel business beta I can
actually but to do that I need to know
fixed and variable costs you know how
often I I correct for operating leverage
almost
never because the information is not
there the exceptions of when I have to
Value company like Southwest in the
airline business Southwest has the most
flexible cost structure of any Airline
it would be unfair for me to attach the
bait of an airline to Southwest it's
flexible cost structure comes from lots
of different choices it makes first it
doesn't fly for the most spot doesn't
fly into the it doesn't fly into hair it
flies into Midway why because the gates
cost less so every choice that Southwest
is made over its life has been to reduce
fix cost the way it pays off is a more
flexible cost structure lower beta so
Airbnb in the hospitality business so
unless you have a company look and say I
need to correct the beta I would just
let it go because the getting the
information and fixed and variable cost
is really tough to do so for the most
part we will assume the operating
leverage with within a sector is the
same but if you have a company that's
exception try to clean up for that which
brings me to financial leverage and here
we know how to adjust
B in fact in 1971 Chicago Professor
Robert Hamada came up with what's called
a Hamada equation what's a Hamada
equation basically he said you tell me
what the beta of the business you're in
you tell me how much you bought with the
debt to equity ratio I can tell you what
the beta of your Equity will be now I'm
going to make it a little confusing
because up till now we've just talked
about beta the unlevered beta is the
beta of the business you're in the lever
beta is the beta of the equity in that
business pause right there can you have
a business that's safe low UNL beta and
end up with a high Equity beta yeah if
you borrow enough money your 30 is if
they were completely Equity funded whe
beta is like 0. 2.3 Banks if they were
entirely Equity funded or bet is like
0.25 what makes their the betas go much
higher is they use a lot of debt and you
can see why they can get away with it if
you have a low UNL beta adding debt
doesn't make you kind of topple over
you're not like an airline where you're
taking a risky business and adding debt
on top of it you have a core business
that's safe so that's called the Hamada
equation it's a it's an equation that's
built into all my spreadsheets but it
comes with a potentially fatal flaw it's
built on the assumption that all of the
market risk in a company is borne by the
investors or put differently it assumes
the beta of debt is zero it doesn't it
doesn't assume that debt is riskless it
just assumes that the risk in debt is
not Market risk just default risk and
that's not a bad assumption if you're
looking at a single a a double A or
Triple B rated company because what
drives those rates has nothing to do
with the company it's driven by what's
happening to the t-bond rate what's
happening in the macro economy but let's
say you have a company with Triple C
bonds
any of you trade in the high yield bond
market high yield bond market it it
behaves a lot like Equity what drives
the bond is more to do with the company
which is another way of saying there is
beta risk or Market risk with that Bond
the bait of that debt is not
zero so when people make this there I
mean people will try to fight you in
every step of the process because they
really want to do whatever they want to
do this all gets in the way so they
don't like the beta you get over that
they'll get to this point say but the
beta of De is not zero okay tell me what
it is that'll usually shut the
conversation down because they just want
say bait of debt is not zero I'll help
them out I'll give them a bait of debt
because if you're Triple C rated I can
figure out what the bait of debt is and
if you can there's actually a version of
the equation where you can bring in the
bait of debt what that effectively does
it transfers some of the market risks to
the lenders which means your bait of
equity will actually be lowered high
debt ratios which actually makes sense
would I take the time to do this for
most companies it's not worth it triple
be single a it's not but if you have a
really high yield bond company Triple C
Double C it might make sense to make
this correction because you want to kind
of parcel out some of the market debt to
the
lenders which leads me to what I call
bottom of an fancy word sounds like I'm
doing something amazing but I'm not
so wi is going to start a company and
I'm going to put him pick any two
businesses you'd like to be make them
fun business don't say steel and
chemicals pick
some Airlines how about Airlines and
cannabis it's a good business to be
right just make sure your Pilots are not
smoking before they get on right so Wht
is in two businesses Airlines and
cannabis and he wants me to estimated
beta for his company so here's what I'm
going to do I'll be back tomorrow with I
go to my office I find as as many
publicly traded Airlines as I can
probably
100 and as many publicly traded cannabis
stocks as I can are there any out there
no there are a lot of them in
Canada the reason you don't have
cannabis stocks in the US is because you
have a patchwork of laws covering the US
and you can't as a company operate in
the US if you're going to be arrested as
you fly from one state to another right
it's a problem so but there are about 30
or 40 cannabis companies in Canada so
publicly traded I get the betas for each
of them then I take the average of the
100 Airline betas and the 100 cannabis
stock betas they're regression betas
right are regression betas lever betas
or unlevered bers levered because the
debt is in the stock prices they reflect
the leverage of airline companies with
the airline bers and cannabis stocks the
Cannabis bers I take out the effect of
the debt using this equation it's called
called unlevering a beta but I'm just
taking out the effect of De I now have
an unlevered beta for being in cannabis
and Airlines I come back to you and say
wait you told me you were in two
businesses can you tell me how much
value you get from each business and
your reaction might be I don't know how
much value I get but I get 80% of my
revenues from Cannabis 20% from
Airlines the only way I can get people
to get on my Airlines is by you know
making them smoke a lot of weight I take
a weighted average of the two unlevered
bays point8 times the Cannabis beta
point I now have an unlevered beta for
your company ready for the last question
I'm going to ask you do you have any
debt if you say no I'm done right the
UNL bet is L beta if you do have debt
I'm going to convert that debt to a debt
to equity ratio say 20% and I'm going to
come up with the lever bait of your
company why am I doing all of this
because I don't like regression betas
right where did I get the 100 Airline
betas regression all I've done is
replaced one regression beta with an
average of 100 I'm going to come back to
you remember those regression betas you
run them right your big standard errors
how is using an average of 100
regression
betas helping me deal with that problem
let's say each of the 100 regression Bas
has a standard a of 0.5 they're all
terrible looking betas noisy
betas what's the a what's the standard
ER of the average of 100 betas going to
look
like remember the law of large numbers
in statistics what the law of large
numbers says and I never got this in my
statistics class you take a 100 crappy
numbers you add them up and divide by
100 and magically you get this really
precise
number but it's not
magic here's what's happening a big
standard means some of these betas are
overestimated right some are
underestimated when I average out guess
what I'm doing I'm averaging out my
SS an average of 100 regression betas is
going to be 10 times more precise than a
single regression beta you saying you're
making up stuff I do sometimes make up
stuff but this one I don't have to make
up how do I get from a sample of 100 to
10 times more precise it's the square
root of the sample you're saying what if
I have only 49 companies I'm picking
nice numbers that you can take the
square root of it's going to be seven
times more precise what if you have only
25 companies five times more precise
what if I have only nine companies three
times more precise anything beats
one so if you're saying I'm using a
regression beta because I have only five
companies guess what the square root of
five is still going to give you a more
precise beta than any single regression
beta I have 48,000 companies in my
public company Sample When I compute
industry average betas there are some
sectors like chemicals where I have 693
companies what AOW allows me to do that
is I cut
across borders when I do betas I'm not
doing just a beta for us companies when
I'm looking at a US company because the
average beta in every single Market is
scaled around one the nice thing about
betas is they travel across borders I
can combine companies in different
markets and still get away with it so
the big I mean I can give you multiple
reasons for bottom of betas but here are
the three biggest ones you get less
noisy
betas you also get more updated betas if
with was just an airline company till
last week and he entered the Cannabis
business last week there is zero chance
at a regression ba will reflect that
right but I can pick weights in fact I
can be proactive and say what other
businesses do you plan to be in and he
might say I'm going to going to the
casino business next week and the
alcohol business the week after he going
full-time into s the anti ESG stock I
can just estimate a beta for him based
on the business I regain control of this
process remember we talked about stories
you tell me a story about your company
doing other stuff I'm going to bring it
into my betas through the
weights and if I came to you with a
private company that's planning to go
public remember the old way you had to
run a regression you can't run a
regression for something that doesn't
have past prices but I can do a bottom
up beta for zato at the time that it
goes public even though it's not been
traded before cuz all I need to know is
what business soato is in and then I can
get a beta for any it gives you the
freedom the flexibility to Value
divisions in know you know private
companies so I'm you know as I said I
don't use regression individual
regression betas in evaluation I haven't
use them in a while because every time I
come to this fork in the road do I want
to go with a single regression or a
bottom of beta to me the bottom of beta
track looks much more
attractive so just to give you a couple
of examples a bottom of betas in space
this is actually a beta page for Val Val
is an iron or Mining Company it's a
Brazilian company and there is the
breakdown of the four businesses that
Vol is in I pause there how would you
know what businesses your companies in
where would you find
this usually in the financials you're
required to you get more than 10% of
your revenues from a different business
both IFRS and GAP required to break it
down that doesn't mean the breakdown is
going to make any sets I've seen
companies break their businesses down
and say what the heck is
that but in most companies this is where
you start V broke themselves down into
four businesses so there are the four
businesses there's my sample to get the
bottom of a and you can see the size of
the sample 693 Global special chemical
you know for the so for each business
and with each of those I get enough
companies in my sample that I feel much
more secure about the unlevered betas
that I get so I have the unlevered betas
of the four businesses what's the final
step I need weights for the four
businesses V actually told me how much
they got his revenues and if I were in a
hurry I would just use Revenue
weights you saying why just not hurry
because a dollar in revenues in one
business can be worth a lot more than a
dollar in revenues in a different
business driven by what usually
difference in margins you're in a low
margin business and a high margin
business the dollar in Revenue in the
high margin business should have a
higher value see that sounds like a lot
of work I used to show shortcut the same
companies from which I get the unlit
betas I look at what multiple of
revenues companies in that space traded
Enterprise so EV is the Enterprise Value
a typical metals and Mining Company
trades at about 1.9 time 97 times
revenues I multiply your Revenue by that
number I come up with an estimated value
so see the second last column those are
my estimates of values of four
businesses I compute weights on this and
based on my numbers
Vol looks like it's about 76% iron or
about 177% metals and Mining about 5%
fertilizers and about 2% Logistics just
make sure the weights add up to
100% take a weighted average I've got an
UNL beta for Val as a
company in my corporate finance class
here's where we'll diverge because there
it's about managing businesses if you
the manager at valy the CEO the CFO the
last thing you should be doing is using
the same cost of equity for these
different businesses right they very
different risk I can now tell you what
the cost of equity should be for each
business because I have a beta for each
business that I can use to build up to a
cost of
equity so not only does it allow me to
manage multi- bus companies it also
allows me to value a division of a
company if Val I think right after I did
it sold its Logistics business if you're
going to sell the logistics business the
beta you would use to value that
divesture would be the beta of the log
istics business not the bait of the
company because ultimately you got it
goes back to the to what we talked about
with the kenot case right you tell me
what you're valuing the target company's
discount rate that should reflect the
risk of the cash
flows that was Vol let's look at imra
Brazilian Aerospace company so when I
first look for peer groups I start
narrow so I said it's Brazilian
Aerospace company let me go find other
public publicly traded Brazilian
aerospace companies and I ran into a bit
of a prom you know what my sample size
looked like one it was embri so
replacing embri with EMB so I said let
me look at Latin American aerospace
companies guess what my sample size
still was one still EMB and then I said
why am I staying focused in Latin
America it's an aerospace company it
makes aircraft to sell to Airlines why
can't I compare it to Boeing and you
know Airbus and that's effectively what
I did I brought in global aerospace
companies and the UNL beta that you saw
for Global Aerospace was 0.95 and I do
this
routinely but there are times when it
might not make sense in other words
using Global
averages when I do this what am I
assuming that your underlying business
risk is the same no matter where in the
world you are and for Aerospace I think
that makes sense it's driven by Airline
demand which has nothing to do with you
know if if you're a mining company I
think it makes complete Sense To Go
Global because what does it matter where
you are ultimately you sell but the
times when it will not make sense of
what I want you to think about
Julian structur you
know how does a let's take any aircraft
company right the fundamental business
model is the same you got to spend huge
amounts building this infrastructure to
make aircraft often with 78 n years of
leading before a new aircraft comes in
that they share in common all all three
now there are company specific
differences right because you might say
look you know the fixed costs are higher
in the US than they are in Brazil I
would love to adjust for that but
fundamentally in Aerospace the model has
stayed the same pretty much for much of
Aerospace history the same thing was
true for automobiles until Tesla kind of
broke open that mod so disruption can
sometimes change it but Aerospace has
been kind of immune from that bomb
bardier you look at Bombardier embri you
know Airbus and Boeing they all have
very similar structures as to how new
aircraft roll out and what the lead time
and lag times are so I'm not sure that
there if there was enough of a
difference I might start to kind of look
at some other sector that be a better so
if you feel the sector doesn't make
sense look for something else that does
well when you do well and does badly
when you do badly right because that's
ultimately what you're looking for now
I'll tell you when you might not I'm on
my web page I do report Global averages
for pretty much every Industry Group and
for a lot of companies I just go with
the global averages but I also report US
averages Europe averages Emerging Market
averages and I do Japan and I throw in
Australian Canada because I'm not sure
where to even put them in to be quite
honest I me they don't quite fit
anywhere else you know when I end up
using Emerging Market averages is you
have a business which is
discretionary in a in in an Emerging
Market but nondiscretionary in the US
and Western Europe used to be true for
Telecom know the early days of Telecom
everybody in the US already had a phone
I'm not talking before
smartphones so you could use the Telecom
beta for you but in much of the rest of
the world a phone was a luxury you would
get to it if you so to the extent that
these countries did well and grew you
might get more sales so if you're
looking for the beta for a telecom
company in those days for an Emerging
Market company it might make sense to
focus just on Emerging Market telecom
companies banking is the other place
where I'm a little reluctant to go with
global averages why because the
regulatory overlay varies across the
world so there I might say look I want
to look at the beta for African Banks if
I'm looking at a Nigerian bank right but
you want you you're walking this very
fine line right because if you try to be
too narrow in your criteria you're going
to end up with too few firms you want to
get enough firms so you get the law of
large numbers working in your
favor one final Point uh in much of what
I do almost all of my valuations I look
at gross debt what's gross debt is the
total debt that you see on the liability
side of the balance sheet two billion
three billion 5 billion in much of the
rest of the world though people talk in
terms of net debt what's net debt you
take the gross debt and you net cash out
so in fact much of Europe when people
talk about debt ratios they're talking
about net debt ratios The netting cash
out and often you get into the issue of
is it okay to use net debt ratios of
gross debt ratio the answer is
absolutely as long as you stay
consistent all the way through let's say
using the gross debt ratio which was 19%
I came up with the beta
1.07 if IID used their net debt ratio I
would have actually end up with a
negative number you saying how is that
possible because a cash balance was
greater than the grow
step don't do things like you know I
can't use a negative number round it
down to zero you have to stick with a
negative net debt ratio what that'll
give you is an unlevered beta that's
actually
lower than I'm sorry lever beta that's
actually lower than your unlever beta if
I just pause there with the beta .93 I'm
going to end up with a much lower cost
of equity than a beta 1.07 right so you
saying isn't that better to have a lower
cost of equity but remember your cost of
equity goes into cost of capital
calculation if I'm doing gross here's
what's going to happen my Beta will give
me a cost of equity it go to into a cost
of capital where the gross debt ratio
will be 15% or 14% based on the debt to
equity ratio which will then give me
cost of capital that's a weighted
average remember debt is cheaper than
Equity it'll pull my cost of capital
down but if I do net debt ratios and I
get a cost of equity based on the net
debt ratio and I compute a cost of
capital what's the weight on My Equity
going to be more than 100% you got to
hang in there your debt ratio will
actually be negative leave it as is the
ending cost of capital you have will
actually be very similar in the both
both the approaches but only because you
stayed consistent so if you feel more
comfortable using net debt ratios I I'm
absolutely okay with that just stay
consistent with that choice all the way
through so let's summarize all of the
different inputs in cost of equity
because I'm we're going to put it to
sleep and start and cost of debt and
capital in the next session risk free
rate Choice driven entirely by currency
nothing to do with incorporation your
Equity risk premium I prefer an implied
premium but if you want to stick with
historical premiums be willing to defend
it make your implicit assumptions
explicit and say this is why I'm going
to do in a
beta don't use a regression beta try to
do a bottomup beta and that might
require that you might have to do some
gymnastics in terms of determining what
business of businesses you're in but I
actually find it less work to estimate a
bottom up beta than a ression beta
because that's why I do the beta I do it
for me so in I value steel company in
the middle of the year I don't start
from scratch I go look up the beta for
steel companies that's what I use
because the betas for businesses should
not change over a week a month or even a
year it's basically a beta that should
be pretty
stable so I will leave you that and see
you on Monday thank you
I'll be coming